c'est marrant depuis à ce soir j'entends
des choses qui trouve écho
parce que c'est un peu ce dont je vais
parler alors que c'est très différent
j'ai quand même un peu plombé l'ambiance
le 13 novembre 2015
j'ai vécu une aventure la plus extrême
de ma vie 13 novembre 2015 j'étais à
votre place dans le bataclan et j'ai eu
la chance ça peut vous paraître être un
oxymore chance et bataclan dans la même
phrase mais j'ai été chanceux je m'en
suis sorti vivant j'ai perdu personne
j'ai été très chanceux parce que j'étais
marié j'avais une femme des enfants des
parents une psy qui m'ont aidé à
supporter tout ça j'ai été chanceux
parce que je savais dessiner c'est mon
métier tu illustrateur médicale j'ai pu
dessiner ce que j'ai vécu
j'ai eu de la chance parce que j'ai
rencontré un éditeur lemieux éditeurs ça
s'invente pas je j'ai vu le bonhomme il
m'a dit son nom je n'en revenais pas je
me suis dit c'est lui j'ai eu de la
chance parce que j'ai pu encore
continuer à vivre tout à l'heure oui
vous expliquer ça c'est exactement ça je
m'en suis mieux sorti mais c'est
exactement ça le 13 novembre la france a
vécu une attaque la plus meurtrière
qu'elle ait connue depuis 70 ans
130 morts 4 113 blessés
99 dans un état critique c'est à dire
que tous ici vous êtes soit mort soit
blessé c'est énorme ça ce ne sont que
les victimes directes
le 13 novembre j'ai passé deux heures
dans l'antichambre de la mort allongé
dans le sang personne n'a compris ce qui
s'est passé moi le premier
odeur de poudre j'ai un des pétards mais
c'est pas en rythme avec la musique
quelque chose ne coïncident pas tout le
monde se jette à terre sans franchement
voir ce qui se passe sans franchement
comprendre s'il est en train de se
passer
moi je me retrouve à six avec la stature
allongé sur les gens assis sur les gens
allongés
je vois les tireurs je les vois nous
tirer dessus
je ne comprends pas je m'allonge malgré
tout en rigolant en disant à tout le
monde
le v vous le dévoué c'est pour rire
je les ai vu son lancer un chargeur pour
tendre à sa fausse je sais je dois être
un peu couillon même beaucoup mais j'ai
pas compris une porte de secours s'est
ouverte sage de l'essuie après est ce
qui était une masse allongé est devenue
une masse mouvante une vague de peur les
gens commençaient très très vite à
sortir et en suivant ce mouvement j'ai
vu une jeune fille se faire marcher
dessus
les deux jambes ballottant au rythme des
fuyards alors prenez pas le terme
fuyards comme un terme péjoratif parce
que quand vous avez trois calèches qui
vous tire dans le dos tout le monde fuit
c'est normal c'est un réflexe j'ai posé
un genou à terre
quelque chose m'a approché pied je sais
pas bien ce qui s'est passé et j'ai
croisé de jeunes le regard d'un jeune
homme mort
là j'ai compris
la jeune fille à côté de moi je vais
proposer de l'aide quand même un petit
peu humain ne pouvait pas se relever
elle était blessée de part en part par
les fesses donc je me suis allongé dans
le sens parce que je me suis dit que
c'était la meilleure des choses à faire
la meilleure cachette on tue pas les
morts normalement et j'ai tenu compagnie
no 7 de jeunes filles devant moi il y
avait un jeune homme je vais demander
comment il allait j'ai pris la main mais
elle était froide je me suis donc
réellement tourné vers cette jeune fille
elisa que j'ai pris pour ma fille ma
petite-fille du bataclan en fait elle
avait 32 ans
et comme j'en ai presque 50 ça allait
puis on s'est tenus compagnie on s'est
tenu des petits mots on a réussi à
s'échanger nos prénoms de date de
naissance là on habitait des petits mots
de soutien c1 c'est rien je vais vomir
un vas-y ça fera plus réaliste un peu
plus tard je vais raconter l'histoire du
pingouin qui respirait par le qu elle la
connaissait pas puis elle a pas écoutés
parce qu'il y avait d'autres bruits
notamment une explosion qui nous a amené
un petit peu plus dans l'horreur nous
couvrons de chair et de sang
puisqu'on était à quelques mètres ce
soir là on a passé deux heures ensemble
deux heures à essayer d'obtenir deux
heures à essayer de se supporter d'être
humains l'un pour l'autre on a créé une
bulle d'humanité
à nous deux une petite bulle une bulle
qui nous tenait
je me disais que je ne pouvais pas
crever que j'ai les trois gosses je me
disais qu'il fallait que je continue les
chaque petit battement était un décompte
du temps de vie qu'on gagne est celui
qui venait de passer parce que le futur
ne connaissais pas j'ai rassuré lisa où
il disant que les coups de feu que l'on
entendait étaient ceux qui ne nous tuez
pas c'est vachement rassurant parce que
j'en avais pas mal donc on pouvait
avancer dans le temps je me suis même
endormi
enfin quasiment endormi visiblement
c'est un réflexe assez courant j'en ai
parlé avec un reporter de guerre médique
sur des lieux je crois que c'est en irak
s'est endormi en plein champ de bataille
mode de protection
on comprend pas donc le cerveau se met
off et puis j'ai réussi à sortir à 23h23
tout de suite bien sûr je préviens ma
femme qui me coûte un peu l'herbe sous
le pied parce que je vais préparer une
bonne blague
chouette concert mais tu as bien fait
pas venir maintenant j'ai pas eu le
temps parce qu'elle avait allumé la
radio et du coup ça faisait une heure
qui s inquiétaient elle avait rameuté
toute la famille donc mes parents
étaient là puisqu'elle est la petite qui
dormait dans la chambre et pouvait pas
partir me rejoindre infirmières super
héros super woman qui voulait me sauver
mais non c'était pas possible j'ai
rejoint ma femme et mon père vers 4h30
du matin place de la bastille ça fait
une demi heure à piéger
enfin même pas une demi heure un quart
d'heure à pied moi j'ai mis une
demi-heure terroriser tout seul couvert
de sang on me demandant si je n'avais
pas rencontré un terroriste fuyant et
quand j'ai vu ma femme et mon père j'ai
vu dans leurs yeux tout sauf ce à quoi
je m'attendais je pensais trouver de la
joie mais nom de l'amour oui de l'effroi
oui de la terreur mais pas de joie
j'ai mis un bout de temps avant de
comprendre qu'il pouvait pas être joyeux
comme moi je l'était pour eux je venais
tout juste de sortir de la mort moi ça
faisait quatre heures que j'ai c'est que
j'en étais sorti ça faisait quatre
heures que je voyais les civières qui
passait ça faisait quatre heures quel
choix y est les sacs plastiques qui
passait quand je suis rentré chez moi
c'était le gros flou une minute une
seconde une heure je ne sais pas je suis
rentré dans une autre dimension
je suis rentré dans une dimension on a
plus de futur je suis rentré dans une
dimension au bataclan est en permanence
dans mes yeux je dors je fais des
cauchemars ce bataclan
je suis éveillé je vois le bataclan je
vois le massacre je vois les copains
j'ai mis très longtemps avant de savoir
par exemple où étaient les copains et
qui j'étais gêné très longtemps avant de
retrouver élise à deux jours ce qui m'a
semblé être une éternité j'ai commencé à
pouvoir rpt dormir c'est à dire 2h 2h 2h
pas d'affilée pour déconner et je me
suis posé cette question mais pourquoi
est ce que je suis en vie maintenant
pourquoi est ce que moi j'ai été épargné
c'est quoi le sens de tout ça qu'est ce
que je dois faire de cette nuit là
c'était tellement douloureux que
j'aurais préféré rester crever plutôt
que de continuer à vivre ça n'a aucun
sens tel est le sens de la vie quand on
sait qu'on peut tuer si facilement qu'on
peut mourir si facilement
quel est le sens de tout ça je ne
trouvais pas
je ne trouvais pas je suis dessinateur
l'idée des dessins mais tu es venu mais
je ne pouvais pas tout dessiné c'était
pas possible je pouvais pas dessiner
tous ces corps ça me ressemble pas c'est
parce que j'aime c'est parce que je veux
dessiner l'émotion l'intention l'epr oui
mais pas dessiner l'horreur il m'a fallu
trois mois de réflexion trois mois avec
ma psy trois mois et les parents en
trois mois à réfléchir pour finalement
trouver les trucs et astuces qui m'ont
permis de dessiner tout ça enfin
dessiner pour moi c'est pas vraiment
encore du dessin parce que c'était
tellement nerveux tellement tendue j'ai
réussi je me suis lancé dedans c'était
le but
un sens à ma vie j'avais retrouvé tout
d'un coup un futur j'avais tout d'un
coup retrouvé une dimension qui allait
au-delà de la seconde au delà de la
minute
je pourrais me projeter sur le but que
j'avais c'est pas pour rien j'ai
commencé par la première planche c'est
la première que j'ai eu en tête dans la
tête sur 15 la première c'est la
dernière celle où je suis dehors je me
suis réapproprié cette soirée par cette
bande dessinée
je me suis réapproprié ma sortie je suis
moi acteur de ma sortie en dessinant et
puis j'ai réalisé autres choses il ya
plein de gens finalement qui vivent des
situations extrêmes en dehors de ce type
de situation et tout d'un coup je trouve
un sens à ça j'ai subi une absence de
futures
on a voulu me priver mon futur on a
voulu de me priver de cette projection
que l'on a tous une anticipation dans la
vie quels sont les gens qui n'ont pas
sain les gens qui décèdent des gens qui
souffrent de maladies des gens qui sont
au chômage
on en parlait à l'instant vous allez me
dire actuellement comparable toi t'as
risquer ta vie ils sont simplement au
chômage
oui mais quand vous êtes en fin de
droits quand vous devez payer les
traites quand vous devez payer la bouffe
quand vous devez habiller les enfants on
en parlait à l'instant c'est exactement
ça vous n'avez plus de futur et cette
absence de futures elle est patent pour
toutes les personnes
imaginez deux un couple qui travaille en
usine
cette usine qui va fermer pour être
transporté à l'autre bout de l'europe
alors qu'elle est rentable
on va pas se demander si dans deux ans
ils vont être en fin de droits comment
ils vont vivre dans deux ans l'ultra
libéralisme est aussi violent que le
terrorisme
l'ultra libéralisme fait autant de
dégâts pas de la même manière il n'y a
pas un fusil d'assaut
non par contre c'est exécute les gens
allaient par centaines on les licencie
et on verra bien ce que ça donne c'est
pas notre problème nous aussi enrichi
c'est tout aussi extrême que ce que j'ai
vécu en france à l'heure actuelle on a
neuf millions de personnes en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
l'équivalent d'un pays comme la suisse
c'est un petit peu moins pour la suisse
je crois que c'est lumineux en allemagne
ils ont 12 points 5 millions de
personnes en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
l'équivalent de la population de l'île
de france donc c'est pas paris c'est
l'île de france c'est énorme
pas mal pour les deux pays forts de
l'europe pas mal pour les deux pays
moteur de notre économie en afrique des
gens crèvent dans des mines pour
extraire le minerai qui va servir pour
les composants de téléphone celui que
j'ai dans la poche
celui que nous avons tous dans la bouche
des enfants en chine vont assembler ces
mêmes téléphone puis après vous
retourner sous une autre forme à
l'afrique dans des décharges illégales
en polluant tout un pays le cas au ghana
par exemple énormément de décharge qui
prive les gens d'un futur en les tuant
c'est l'ultra libéralisme je ne fais pas
de distinguo simplement dans la forme
politique idéologique religieux les
extrêmes on se tue nous mêmes par appât
du gain
froidement par idéologie mais en ce nul
grâce au défunt j'ai retrouvé un avenir
j'ai retrouvé un sens à ma vie et on a
tous besoin de cet avenir
on a tous besoin d'un sens à notre vie
et j'aimerais bien qu'on travaille
ensemble humain pour le retrouver
merci
[Applaudissements]